who edits my videos
so i got a great question for one of my
loyal youtube viewers love you guys
leonardo who wrote in to say what's up
evan who edits your videos what's up leo
if you want to know what's up you can
check out my what's up video and in
terms of who edits my videos i want to
tell you a quick story that i hope will
help see i'm a big believer in not
spending money until i'm making money
for those of you loyal youtube viewers
you'll know what i'm talking about it's
a message i repeat in a lot of my videos
when i started my youtube channel i
wanted to have a place to have a greater
impact and help people in a visual way
but i wasn't making any money at it so i
didn't want to spend anything i didn't
spend on editing i didn't spend on gear
i didn't spend it on anything but i was
willing to invest my time and my hustle
so stage one for me was actually
partnering up a buddy of mine named mark
drager runs a video production company
called phantom media he's been on the
channel a few times i've interviewed him
and we started together where i would be
on camera and he would film it and edit
it and produce it and then i would
publish it to the channel he did it
because i guess he wanted to be a friend
to me and he also saw a promotional
angle to get some exposure for his
business but after a while it got to be
too taxing for mark and his team to
handle i was making too many videos and
he wasn't i guess seen enough of return
to continue on with me i still wasn't
making enough money to justify hiring an
editor so my stage two was i did it
myself now i was by no means a video
editor i had no skills no training
didn't know what i was doing i started
by using windows movie maker and a lot
of the early videos on my channel are me
editing my windows movie maker videos as
i needed more features and i learned a
little bit more about video editing
software i picked up camtasia and
started using that as my default editor
but i was still doing all the work
myself as i built up my audience and i
started getting a little bit of traction
with the channel
a big company in the telecommunications
space said they wanted to work with me
on a video they gave me a little bit of
a budget to play with and now that i was
making some money from my channel i
could afford to invest it back into the
channel so one of the first things i did
was put out a job on odesk and i hired
my first video editor sa'ad and saad was
great and reliable and i would upload
the videos to him on dropbox he would
send them back to me and i would put
them up on my channel and then one day
sa'ad poof
disappeared and now suddenly i was stuck
having to edit all these videos myself
and it really sucks as an entrepreneur
when you hire somebody and you finally
give away those responsibilities
that you don't want to have anymore
yourself and then you have to take them
back on you really really really don't
want to do them saad went from being
super reliable to not responding to any
email for two weeks so i said enough is
enough i have to go find somebody new to
help me edit these videos because i
can't keep doing this myself and that's
where i found christina
christina say hi
and christina's been doing a fantastic
job for me she's been editing all the
videos she's been posting them to
youtube she's been adding in the title
in the description and saved a lot of my
time so that i can spend more of my time
being in front of the camera instead of
being in front of the computer editing
them now i later found out that sa'ad
actually got kidnapped and he was out
for two months and held for ransom and i
guess that was something that was
relatively normal in his country but by
the time he came back i had christina
who was doing an amazing job and who i
wanted to keep on board on my team so
those are my three steps i started with
alliance partners then i started doing
it myself and then as i started making
money from my channel i was able to go
out and hire somebody to help me do it i
hope that answers your question leonardo
believe
for those of you watching i would love
for you to tell me who your first hire
was what their role was i don't care
about their name but what was their role
what what job function did they have in
your business or if you're thinking
about hiring somebody who's the first
person that you want to hire for your
business to take some stuff off your
plate leave in the comments below i'm
really curious to see what you guys are
thinking and of course if you like this
video and you want to see more don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
to the newsletter thank you so much for
watching i'll see you soon